des made you roll mignotte guerre des
gemmeurs man bas depuis d'elles est vite
en m vos demeures art modem ce qui veut
dire
chers amis bienvenue à guidel pour la
grande assemblée donc le congrès du
modem que nous sommes heureux à guidel
d'accueillir une fois de plus on vous
feront vous voir revenir avec plaisir un
vieux dicton dit que guidel on y vient
et on y revient je vois que vous ne le
fait pas mentir et ça nous réjouit tous
j'ai compris que mon temps de parole est
limitée dont vous parlez aujourd'hui
l'environnement je vais rester discuter
je voulais juste vous faire remarquer
que vous aviez tout à l'heure en fond
d'écran la photo d'une très belle plage
je sais pas si on peut la revoir en tout
cas je vais vous donner son nom officiel
je suis sûr que vous ne l'oublierai pas
ça s'appelle la crique des amoureux et
ça fait plus d'un siècle que cette plage
la porte ce nom officiel vous pouvez
regarder sur voilà et vous voyez autour
lèche les sentiers de randonnée qui y
mène vous voyez les escaliers qu'on a pu
faire pour dessins etc etc ces dindes et
un des endroits les plus protégés auquel
on tient tous mais certains pour des
raisons bien particulière en tout cas
bon congrès à tous et au plaisir
[Applaudissements]
et bien voilà deux amoureux de la crique
qui arrive sur scène
pour vous dire combien on est combien on
est heureux de vous retrouver combien ça
fait du bien de retrouver cette
université entrée du modem merci
françois de l'avoir voulu parce que nous
étions en réunion et françois a dit on a
une université cet été
oui oui oui petites ou grandes grande a
dit françois et nous voilà tous ce soir
et on est heureux d'être là bonsoir à
tous et à toutes françois nos
parlementaires nos militants c'est
effectivement comme le dj un grand
plaisir de retrouver la famille du
mouvement démocrate ici en bretagne de
saluer la fédération du morbihan toute
l'équipe du siège qui nous accueille
merci à eux et forcément je me retourne
aussi vers mes collègues députés
européens on est à j moins 99 avant la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne un moment important
pour nous qui avons toujours affirmé que
l'europe faisait partie des solutions
alors remercié évidemment monsieur le
maire de guidel remercier de sa présence
le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de lorient je voudrais
qu'on félicite nos morbihannais élu au
conseil départemental
je pense à notre président mohamed azgag
je pense là stéphane lohézic je pense à
roven guégan et je pense à ma région le
breton on en a placé quatre françois
c'est quand même pas si mal et puis
voilà bien une pelle un beau week-end
des plénières des ateliers je vous
attends demain 15h30 pour parler
arctique et antarctique
mais merci surtout à tous profiter bien
ces moments et on est tous ensemble pour
poursuivre sur cette belle aventure
merci à tous merci brasse
[Applaudissements]